hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
and i'm
just checking in
just checking in on you
what's going on how are you
how's things i just watched my boston
red sox
finally beat the goddamn blue jays jesus
christ
that [ __ ] springer that kid's killing
us absolutely killing us and i gotta
tell you you know
yeah i gotta admit i gotta admit they
they got a good squad god damn it it
kills me and you know and who's kidding
who boba shet love the highlights
the highlights in his hair it's just you
know it's not enough that he's a
shortstop in the mlb
it's not enough that he has long flowing
hair he also has to get him highlighted
i mean jesus christ i mean what the [ __ ]
more do you need to do
um all jealousy
and then i did enjoy uh jordan romano
the look on his face he looks like
[ __ ] teen wolf
he was not [ __ ] around um i think we
caught him in between growing a beard
because i had to look him up
to be like does he always look like that
i just think it was the intensity of
that game because you see a photo of the
guy he looks fine but when he's sitting
there with his glove up to his face
you know and he's doing the full metal
jacket you know you kind of put your
head down you look through the bottom of
your eyebrows
um mildly unsettling for a baseball
player
um
anyway
and how about your boston celtics
oh freckles oh billy [ __ ] knees was
like let's not get too confident
after being up two games to none and
seeing all those meathead celtics fans
walking not saying all celtics fans are
meatheads i mean the drunks that walk up
to the cameras
after the game's over going four
and four guess what they were right
what a surprise i'm always i used to be
writer before i had kids and i got busy
i used to be right about sports a lot i
cannot remember oh wait a minute i beat
the book this year against the spread in
football so i did all right there uh but
i did lose diversity first he did better
than me
um
but i remember after game two i was
saying that you know i don't know we
came out we had sunglasses on and for
the [ __ ]
the after party there with the press and
i just saw that look on kevin durant's
face and he had he had that marvin gaye
red knitted hat on and i was just going
like i i just don't think that these
guys
uh think are thinking the way those
celtics fans are saying in four but it
turns out
those meathead celtic fans were right
and old man billy was wrong once
again
once again i was wrong so i'm looking
forward to the celtics because you know
beyond the fact obviously i want to see
him
win another championship
um
i'm also looking forward to you know
when we play the bucks i'm assuming they
closed out the bulls i didn't see the
the score but i'm looking forward
to the long
awaited rematch
the grudge match
returned from that that that uh grayson
allen two flagrant fouls in the summer
league game
against one of the nicest guys in the
nba grant williams i mean that guy can
just cannot get a [ __ ] call
and that guy is just completely
i don't know what all of a sudden he's
hitting every three pointer he takes
he's playing a great game and grayson
allen has cleaned up his game but we'll
see what happens
you know everybody's going to be talking
about uh
the greek freak
ante tecumpo right
and everybody's gonna be talking about
jaylen uh jalen rosen's [ __ ] uh
jason williams right and all the celtics
smart
but i'm going to be watching grant
williams
well you watched jaylen brown as i
almost called him jaylen rose
uh [ __ ] you i got two kids under five
i'm trying the fact that i know
anybody's name is amazing
i'm going to be watching
the first time grant williams sets a
screen
on grace and alec to see what happens
does it reignite the fire
you know it's one of the great nba
rivalries grudge matches that nobody
talks about you know you know espn they
don't have the nerve to talk about this
type of stuff the way i do
um
anyway i am back out here
uh back out here in l.a i'm so psyched
to be back out here with my family and
all that i'm literally sitting here i
just reached down i have a pacifier
in my pocket
you know
i'm living the dad life here i was
sitting on for the ninth inning eighth
and ninth inning my daughter was
literally sitting on my chest
not on my my lap she was sitting on my
chest she thought it was funny
that i couldn't see the game and she was
looking at her little ipad
which i don't like i don't like the
ipads and all of that [ __ ]
you know they [ __ ] sit there and they
hold him like two feet away from him so
we got a little stand and it's like all
right you can do this
the kid's always like i don't want to do
that you know
i want to hold it like right up to my
face and you sit there and be like
you're going to need glasses and they
just they they don't listen and it's the
end of the day and they wear you out
and you know i don't know
i don't know what i don't know if my
kids look at me as much as i'm a dad as
i'm a jungle gym
because then my son comes in and he's
jumping on my shoulder and stuff oh
billy's shoulders oh billy old shoulders
all right
my rehab's you know
my rehab's coming back here
my rehab's coming back no my shoulders
are coming back
so i'm able to uh i bought this [ __ ]
thing on the internet i got to give
these guys a shout out but i don't know
i don't know what the name is i'll do it
on the monday morning podcast i bought
this thing
where it almost looks like a medieval
weapon that's the only my only
knock against it is the fact that it
looks like a medieval weapon
i don't dare bring it to the airport
because they're like what the [ __ ]
that
when you start swinging around and take
over the plane no no i was i was born
here i'm i'm happy here
i'm not trying to ruin here i just have
old shoulders they'll just be like yeah
whatever
i'm from massachusetts man i got a
rotator cuff issue
tell it to the tsa
[ __ ] face right i know they're gonna
take it away from me so what it is
is it's just a it's a handle
with a little cord and then it comes
with uh
three different size balls ladies um and
some gentlemen um
and it works its way up in weight
and all you do is you hold your stand
you have your shoulders down you hold it
straight out
you do 30 you're just
moving your wrist but somehow this helps
the rotator cuff and i can tell you my
rotator cuffs feel great
you do 30 clockwise with both hands
straight
arms straight out as if you were
beginning to be a nazi and then thought
better of it you only go like
he only goes
you only go uh
straight up okay you don't go you go
seek you don't get to the heil part you
just do a seek no the seeks to the chest
right
if i got my hate group [ __ ] down right
um you just don't go up
all right
whoever has this product is so happy
that i don't know the name of it i'm
tying the nazis into this and then you
go you rest and then you do the same
position
and then you go uh you go 30 clock
counterclockwise you rest
again um
and then
you do it at like a 45 degree angle same
thing
you know hand at the shoulder and then
you do it all the way out to the side
clockwise counterclockwise in each
position so it's a total of like 12 reps
three different positions
on each side
and uh i gotta tell you you do it ten
days with each one of the bulls there
and each ball gets a little bigger and a
little heavier and you gradually work
your way up and i gotta tell you
it's been helping me out i've been going
to the gym i'm doing the lat pull downs
everything's fine i'm doing that one
that everybody does the exercise wrong
you know the one where you lean forward
it's almost like you're rowing a boat
and you get those people they just grab
on to it they're just rocking back and
forth like they're going up the charles
river right all they're doing i don't
know what they're working it's like
their lower back
um
the amount of people that do that
exercise wrong myself included you're
supposed to feel it between your
shoulder blades
the bottom of your trapezius
which i learned because i have 80
shoulders because all i did was bench
curl and [ __ ] tries for upper body
and shoulders we just did like the
military press and my shoulders rotated
forward and that's why i have the
problem so i'm trying to get my
shoulders to come back
you know what i mean so i'm not caving
in on myself
all right so the one man thrill ride
won't eat a bowl of cereal out of my
chest
um
anyway and we i got another thing here
that i want to uh
bring to your guys attention if you can
help out
do you like helping out fellow americans
um
steve simone
great comedian and one of the great uh
just
just people he's always helping people
out well there's a family
that was going through some stuff uh a
year and a half ago and some comics got
together and we were able to help them
out you know and unfortunately uh one of
their kids is going through something
right now
um
is suffering from ple which i was
looking that up i don't know what it is
they're trying to raise 15 grand to help
this kid out
they got five and a half grand at this
point
i'm gonna donate some money
uh it's a gofundme
uh
for monique esparza is organizing this
fundraiser so i imagine that's the
mother somebody
and the kid's name is maceo so uh i'm
gonna post the gofundme to my twitter
if you can throw a couple of shekels
that way that would be awesome
um yeah you know help some people out
instead of screaming at somebody on the
internet tonight let's say
we do that if we're in the mood if not
if you're not on the move
you want to go on facebook and argue
politics
um
you know what's [ __ ] hilarious what
i've been doing lately on instagram
is
you know that's that's stupid self-help
[ __ ]
you know what i mean like where they're
just like you know
the lion isn't
the fastest
animal he's not the strongest animal
and he's not the smartest animal but
when he walks into an area everybody
shuts the [ __ ] up right and everybody
underneath in the comments is just like
this
amazing
i need to remember this
it's like first of all that just sounds
like you know
you're going to live your life like a
suge knight type of guy you know what i
mean and [ __ ] put your cigar out on
people's foreheads that doesn't sound
like you're gonna be like a nice
empathetic person
anyway so these stupid self-help things
um somehow when i was in new york i was
talking to uh
rachel feinstein [ __ ] hilarious
comedian and we've been joking around so
i've been sending her those
and we just sort of make fun of them
and but because i keep
sending them to her
they think that
instagram thinks that i like this [ __ ]
you know what i mean like if you if you
kick click on guitars
if you click on fitness models air quote
fitness models
gym horse
um
this is a good exercise for your abs oh
yeah do you have to do it in a thong
you're working your abs why are you
bending over you know what the worst
thing about that is you look at one of
those things
one of them the next [ __ ] time you
hit that magnifying glass there's gonna
be like nothing but asses in your face
and then your wife's looking at you like
it's like i clicked on one of them
i mean what am i supposed to do here
she's putting it in the camera um
so anyway i've been clicking on those
stupid self-help ones i bet i can find
one right now i hope it won't click off
my uh
my uh my recording it probably will here
no it still seems like it's on let me
see if i can find one
um oh find one that i sent they're so
[ __ ] dumb
half of them they're not even like
self-help
and of course nothing's loading where
the hell okay here we go
this is just gonna be
all right let me see here usually the
other words
oh i'm not here to compete
i'm here to change the game
and then they play their win
that stupid [ __ ] thing that they
always play
and then people like send that to other
people i'm not here to compete i came
here to change the game oh did you
you know everybody [ __ ]
i don't know
why are you posting that you're not
michael jordan all right you're just a
regular [ __ ] idiot like me all right
just stop stop with the lions
you know what they should do you know
they do that thing if you were a famous
person or something they do that face
swap thing whatever that dumb [ __ ] is
that people do
they should re they should do a thing
like a real an accurate one
because i know that they have them
whether like if i was an animal what
would i be and it's always like you're
an eagle you're a bear
you know what i mean you're never like
some varmint you know what i mean you
know you're a [ __ ] possum
you sleep all day you don't do [ __ ]
[ __ ] hanging around right and then
what at night you come out
and you try to [ __ ] scavenge you
[ __ ] bum off other people you know i
know plenty of people like that
especially now that weed is legal
you know what i mean you got that you
got uh you got
was it uh bpe big big possum energy
sorry kids
um i'm trying to use the i'm trying to
be hip here man trying to use the
younger slogans yeah it's just like stop
[ __ ] telling everybody that they're
lions
and not to mention acting like lions are
so goddamn smart
all right although i did see one jump on
a giraffe the other day so it would
freak out run away from its baby
it's weird sometimes i root for lions
and then other times i don't i root for
them against hyenas
hyenas are like the hecklers of [ __ ]
the jungle i know you'd think that
they're the comedians because they're
laughing but they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
um i don't like them i don't like
baboons i root for i root for leopards
this is where my my
loyalty is
like uh first of all baboons are no joke
all right i respect them the way i
respect the yankees okay but the end of
the day i don't [ __ ] like them okay
um
every once in a while
you know leopards usually are just like
all right i understand
that you have a mouth full of teeth like
i do
like baboons have insane [ __ ] canines
and i know
some [ __ ] animal douche is gonna
write in and be like oh actually the uh
the the [ __ ] bite pressure of a
baboon is one and a half times that of a
leopard so um yeah
the leopard runs away
um
every once in a while like a leopard
doesn't leave
you know and you see the baboon's a bit
of a punk right not a bit of a punk but
the baboon is like you know i i respect
it okay
the [ __ ] leopard eats baboons so it's
it's the baboons the baboon's basically
the dad right he's got to be like all
right there's an intruder here the moms
are like okay
go get him
dad
he has to [ __ ] go over there
and [ __ ] with this leopard you know
it's already intimidating i would think
for the baboon because the leopard is
way better looking right
nobody has a baboon fur coat right
nobody does leopard yes absolutely
absolutely it's [ __ ] beautiful at
least a fake leopard one
nowadays so some [ __ ] doesn't [ __ ]
spray paint your coat after you bought
it
um
by the way here's my question do these
[ __ ] peter [ __ ] do they ever do that
to a pimp i don't think i've ever seen a
pita [ __ ] throw paint on a pimp's coat
they usually wait for some [ __ ]
stay they go they're really big on going
after socialites
you know they're kind of like baboons
right well i guess a baboon [ __ ] with a
leopard
who's kidding who i don't really even
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
this point but that's what i look at
when i'm on when i'm on instagram
i look at
animals killing each other i look at old
trucks
uh drummers
and what else
and these self-help [ __ ] things and i
have to stop sending them to rachel
because i am just [ __ ] inundated with
these goddamn things yes i did just use
that big word and i pronounced it
correctly i think
i'm sure if i didn't that's another
thing the baboon guy is going to come at
me for right
um
it's a nun date
for your own edification and there's no
s at the end of any way
okay
um
so plowing ahead
i ran into somebody
today and
they were like hey man i saw you threw
the you threw a strike you know good for
you blah blah we started talking about
people who threw the ball out and we
both agreed
all right i'ma see if you guys can guess
who
non-baseball player
had the greatest first pitch ever
as far as i'm concerned there's only one
answer
as far as the level of pressure this
person was dealing with the time with
which they did it and where they did it
and the [ __ ] dude through gas and
through a [ __ ] strike
who do you got
liberals are not gonna like this answer
george w bush
right after 9 11
he's coming in there the country needed
a strike
he's in yankee stadium the house that
babe ruth built
right
he's at basic he's basically ground zero
of [ __ ] baseball history
what did they have they had 26
championships at that point
and he came out on the mound they
brought him in he had a flak jacket on
and a [ __ ] eagle was going to come in
after him if he bounced that ball
ugh
it would have been brutal the guy went
up there not only throws a strike he
throws [ __ ] gas
and he must have been like what in his
50s [ __ ] he was probably
a couple years older than me
um that's my
all-time
greatest uh first pitch ever thrown out
i got to go with george w bush now
i'm sure somebody you know
is gonna pick somebody else
um
but i remember that and i remember
people talking about man he [ __ ]
threw that thing didn't he
it was a good it was a good thing it was
a good thing um
all right let me do some reads here for
the week where the [ __ ] am i all right
we got a couple of reads here
uh bowling branch everybody
you know bowling branch sheets aren't
just buttery
breathable and impossibly comfortable
they get softer with every wash
uh you know what a lot of people don't
know that so do i
every shower i take i get a little
dumber uh forget thread count bowling
branch gives you thread quality
yeah that's a big thing and what's the
thread count that's what everybody asks
and they don't even they don't even know
what the [ __ ] it means myself included
right anyway because it doesn't matter
how many threads your sheets have if
they aren't the best threads possible
see this
it's quality over quantity bowling
branch uses the highest quality threads
on earth for superior softness and a
better night's sleep that's not to say
somebody can't go to outer space and
come up the better but as far as this
planet goes it's not going to get softer
than these guys sheets made with threads
so luxurious
they're beloved by three u.s presidents
only one of whom through a [ __ ]
strike
um
they feel buttery to the touch and are
super breathable so they're perfect for
every season over ten thousand stellar
reviews
bowling branch signature sheets come in
nine versatile colors in all size from
twin up to california king you'll
immediately feel the difference of their
iconic signature sheets
uh they're 100 free from toxins meaning
no pesticides formaldehyde or harsh
chemicals no wonder i have nightmares so
i got to get some new sheets [ __ ]
sitting here breathing in chemicals
bowling branch sheets fit the deepest of
mattresses
and are labeled with top and bottom tags
so making your bed is easier than ever
deepest of mattresses i was just
picturing some [ __ ] tub of [ __ ] just
causing a
creating a valley in the middle of his
uh
mattress that's not what they mean how
thick it is
like a burger like a patty best of all
you know what's funny you guys all
understood that and i felt the need to
explain it to you because i didn't get
it best of all bowling branch gives you
a 30-night risk-free trial with free
shipping and returns on all orders miss
the bowling branch april sale don't
worry about it buddy we got you my
listeners get exclusive access to all
to post wait my listeners get exclusive
access to a post sale
20
site-wide discount through the end of
april with the promo code burr b-u-r-r
at bowl and branch dot com b-o-l-l
for all you bowlers out there b-o-l-l
and branch
uh dot com that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code bur
uh burr for 20 off through the end of
april
and next look what we got here oh it's
simply safe
you guys
you guys know i love the break-in
protection that my simply save home
security system gives me yeah i love
that and also watching the possums and
raccoons on the footage
running around my [ __ ] trash barrels
at night i knew those weren't cat paw
prints
uh actually a person doesn't have paws
shut up
uh but it's not always outside forces
that you that you need simply saves
protection from this is joshua's story a
simply saved customer from indiana
indiana oh jesus christ i'm guessing
meth head or a crazy farmer with a
sickle
okay let's see what happened a few
months ago he fell asleep with pizza
rolls still in the oven
the [ __ ] kind of story is i thought this
was a break-in
okay
let's make sure we get the name right
what is this guy's name joshua
oh i think weed is legal in indiana man
josh you know he swung by the store for
some medicinal help to go to sleep man
so he puts his pizza rolls in the oven
man it was like far out i got a
pepperoni and a sausage man this all
could have been disastrous
uh he fell asleep thousands are passed
out depending on whatever this lunatic
was doing thousands of dollars in damage
to his kitchen or home or worse could
have happened luckily
joshua has comprehensive simply safe
system
equipped with everything to print to
prevent break-ins and smoke detectors to
sniff out fires
he startled awake to the sound of a 95
decibel alarm hey harsh in the mellow
man
from his simply safe base station
seconds later he got a call from a
simply safe professional monitor are you
smoking weed against son you got pizza
in the oven get off your ass put out the
fire protecting people
anyways the pizza rolls didn't make it
but joshua did that's great that's a
great story that's a feel-good story he
believes simply safe probably saved his
life that night
you know i'm going to get an email from
this guy talking about how he actually
works 60 hours a week ends a member of
the national guard and that's why he was
tired uh protecting people when their
guard is down is just one of the reasons
more than 4 million people use and love
simply safe with a comprehensive simply
safe system and 24 7 professional
monitoring you're all you always have
someone looking out for you plans cost
under one dollar a day it's a dollar a
day to not die in a [ __ ] pizza fire
with no long-term contracts or hidden
fees ever you can customize the perfect
system for your home in just a few
minutes at simply safe.com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring go to simply
safe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash burr
man
um all right
you know when i was a kid speaking of
pizza they used to have these frozen
pizzas
before frozen pizzas they had these
little ones they were little bite-sized
pizzas and there was like either 9 or 12
to like a sheet right and you take out a
sheet
and maybe it's just a box that's you
just had the one right there with these
little circle ones they're probably
i don't know
i'd say a little more than
half the size of a hockey puck in in
like circumference right and one whole
row was sausage
the other whole row was pepperoni and
the other whole row was cheese
okay and i come from the latchkey
generation
your parents both were at work they
shared a car
you lived in a duplex
you know what i mean it's one of those
deals
you want to have fun christ you went
outside you climbed that tree how old do
i sell um anyway
so we used to come home
and we used to turn on the oven because
that's what you do
i just realized that
your parents aren't home they gave you a
key and now you're turning on the oven
and there was no simply safe back then
man
you were on your own
that's what's wrong with these
millennials man
um we're all like 40 now aren't they um
isn't it time to blame another
generation for [ __ ] that
older generations created
the millennials let me give you let me
give you a little
a little forecast here you're going to
do the same thing um it's what you do
unless you become one of the rare the
rarest thing on the planet a cool old
guy
a cool old guy who lived the life he
wanted to live
found the woman he wanted to be with and
therefore is happier happy for young
people and encourages them
rather than telling them everything
they're doing is wrong
i'll tell you what i did was wrong is i
ate chinese food too fast
now i have the hiccups
anyway so we turned the stove on as you
do
and we'd throw those [ __ ] in there
and we would sit down and we would just
[ __ ] chow those things
and it was either that or they had these
things called stakehomes which i know
i've brought up a zillion times so i
won't bore you with it again but those
were the big ones
or you just came home
and you ate donuts
and back in the day you didn't buy
donuts at a donut place unless it was
after church other than that he had
donuts
that god knows when they were made
somebody made these [ __ ] things and
they put them on a truck and they were
driven states
across states
all right and then you [ __ ]
they just stuck them in a goddamn
supermarket and i know they still have
donuts and supermarkets and i got to be
honest with you you know
there's something really cool about
having donuts in your house
if you just don't give a [ __ ] right
that's always been like the big thing
for me if you're eating donuts you don't
give a [ __ ]
i know the expression is cake eater but
you know you got to be honest dude
there's not a lot of places to get cake
but [ __ ] donuts especially out here
in la
for a city that is so goddamn vain well
at least hollywood is let's not blame
all of la by the way
all right there's plenty of people that
like guns
four-wheelers and [ __ ] you know
reality show tv stars with long ties
there's plenty of those people out there
they're just not right in hollywood
but anyway
he used to buy these [ __ ] donuts and
they had three rows
they had powdered they had cinnamon and
they had the [ __ ] plain ones
and the plain ones
was for the weakest of the herd
all right all the siblings came home
all right and the oldest ate high on the
hog ate the cinnamon and the powdered
and then the [ __ ] the weak ones
would just get the plain ones and every
once in a while they'd try to sneak a
powdered one
and then they'd get beat down
and that was the 70s everybody and that
is the podcast sorry
that was a sad story of children getting
beaten over powdered sugar
donuts
you know and i'll tell you right now i
think that's why this country's so
[ __ ] up
the way it is today it ain't social
media it's them powdered donuts from the
supermarket back in 1975.
um
all right
that is the uh that is the podcast oh by
the way i'm getting my [ __ ] car fixed
i told you my son closed the [ __ ]
gate on it
it was hilarious
i was like how the [ __ ] did i hit that i
never hit the gate in my [ __ ] life
how did i sideswipe that thing and i
looked up and he was just [ __ ]
standing in the window he somehow got
the controller
and he's [ __ ] pressing on the froot
with all his might
so
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do all right that is
the podcast congratulations to my boston
red sox hey blue jay fans
congratulations you guys you got a hell
of a [ __ ] squad
jesus christ you know if they're half as
good as their hair is that tilapia guy
whatever the [ __ ] his name is [ __ ]
walking around
looking like he's about ready to drop a
hit album
who has [ __ ] white extensions nobody
you know i like about that guy he
doesn't he doesn't give a [ __ ] about a
cutoff man he always throws to the plate
all right that's it the bruins tonight i
think this is their final home season uh
regular season game it's got to be
they're playing the buffalo sabers
and then it's playoff time
it's playoff time you got the basketball
and the hockey playoff and in the middle
the connective tissues you watch a
little bit of baseball this is [ __ ]
fun it's one of the great times of the
year it's just it's reverse october
where october you have the baseball
playoffs you got [ __ ]
football
and you got basketball and hockey start
i don't know i like this time of year
we got you guys because you only have
baseball playoffs everything else is
just sort of starting this time of year
baseball's starting
and you got two of the four sports are
going in the playoffs we get it bill all
right whatever i'm excited all right
listen to the uh little bit of music
here
a little interlude and then we're gonna
play a bonus half hour
um thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast that is it have a
great weekend you [ __ ] oh bye i didn't
talk f1
dude formula one if you're gonna jump in
this is the [ __ ] year to jump in
all right
max verstappen and red bull
i believe they went one and two i had
the sound down i was on the road
[ __ ] editing this damn movie
and uh but i was watching the thing
um i don't know what happened with
ferrari on this one
but i think ferrari they're still in the
lead is the driver and i also believe is
the team red bull not only did they
finally finish a goddamn race they went
one and two
and then uh
mercedes other driver whatever his name
is came in fourth so they're hanging in
there for whatever reason
uh lewis hamilton was in 14th place and
i would have loved to have the volume on
and limus habitat is in 14th place
um i would have loved to listen to that
but what i'm loving about this
is finally there's people that can
compete against mercedes and the best
part is do you think mercedes is gonna
suck all year do you think lewis
hamilton is not
[ __ ] sitting there right now being
like guys i am not gonna be driving a
car that's gonna come in 14th [ __ ]
place
he's gonna [ __ ] snap on all of those
guys in a good way in a leadership way
and they're gonna get his car where it
needs to be and the best thing in
formula one there's nothing like
watching lewis hamilton have to play
catch-up and all these years all it was
was just hoping he didn't get pole
position and didn't win the first turn
and then he got to see a little bit of
racing now
it's phenomenal and shout out to whoever
that poor woman is on espn who has to
announce that we're going to commercial
but you won't miss any race i feel like
she's probably getting cursed out by
race fans
um
because if you've been watching it over
here i don't know this is like the
second year in a row that they do this
[ __ ] over here where now that espn has
it they have to have their [ __ ]
commercials
um and that's why you tape it to fast
forward through but don't take it out on
her people it's not her fault it's
espn's
espn the same people
who are too afraid
to talk about the grayson allen
grant williams
collision that is coming
all right in the next round okay i'll
talk to you guys later
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
april 28 2014.
what's going on how are ya i am uh
recording this at uh
i'm actually recording it sunday night i
just finished doing my show
here in albany um
at this beautiful theater i don't even
[ __ ] know the name of
well look at that
would you look at that and you're
probably like why bill you arrogant ass
everybody came down to the [ __ ] show
you don't even know the name of the
place
well the reason for that is is uh i've
been on vacation and uh i felt like i
was shaking rust off
this weekend i had good shows and
everything but i was more trying to
remember the order of things
how i kind of did [ __ ]
and what connected to what and uh
whenever i do that i'm in my head too
much and then i don't
it doesn't flow as well um
you know
only i noticed but i noticed
so uh either way i want to thank
everybody who came out in burlington
vermont
um
people who came out in portland maine
and people came out here in uh albany
new york
it was great to come back to this part
of the country i did a lot of my early
stand-up
especially up in maine i used to do all
the bob miley gigs up there
and uh
the old comedy connection up there i
used to do and um i didn't do too much
[ __ ] in vermont
you know vermont is a uh
i don't know that's like it was just a
little i was south of boston so you know
you drove up 93 or route 3 you [ __ ]
went in new hampshire then you shot
right into maine that was basically at
that little corner of it that i went to
and um so this time when i came back
from burlington vermont to portland i
could have i could have driven the fast
way but i decided to go the scenic route
i'm gonna go to the city crew and see
what the country looks like and i
[ __ ] went there and it was amazing to
look at but i like i kept getting stuck
behind people in like minivans or trucks
and i'm driving like a psycho and after
a while there's only so many furniture
stores and barns and
old places with signs that you can look
at before you want to get the [ __ ] out
of there but um
we had a great time at vermont i didn't
realize they had the heroin problem they
did
you know i didn't bring it up during the
show because it was so not funny but
jesus christ
how the [ __ ] is there heroin
like that level of a problem in vermont
vermont's like one of those states where
you know you finally knock up your woman
you're like you know what
why don't we give this kid a great
childhood
and where should we move this kid
where no one can hurt him and he can
[ __ ] run around with horses and all
of that [ __ ] right
and uh you you know vermont's one of
those places
oh that's right they had it in rolling
stone the new face of heroin
the explosion of drugs like oxycontin
has given way to the heroin epidemic
ravaging the least likely corners of
america
jesus christ
like
vermont what does it say how do you
pronounce b-u-c-o-l-i-c
b-u-c-o-l-i-c
bucolic
[ __ ] vermont
which has just woken up to a full-blown
crisis
you know ever since aids came out not a
lot of people say full-blown anymore so
i want to give i want to give rolling
stone a good nod there
you know
i was talking about a while ago i was
looking at theaters to do a new special
in an inside on old theater is the only
time you use the word ornate and another
example is full-blown full-blown is only
used with aids
i mean what did they say i'm trying to
think of free aids do i [ __ ] remember
we're full-blown we got a full-blown
epidemic
i'll tell you last night i went to the
bathroom after that mexican food i took
a full-blown [ __ ] i don't know what
people used to say
ever since i can remember since the mid
80s
full-blown has always been followed with
aids
look how much progress we've made with
that disease not only can people live
longer
with hiv virus you can actually now say
full-blown crisis
that's a major that's a major movement
you know
um anyways
i gotta read this whole thing
i gotta read this whole thing it was i
was terrible to see because it's such a
beautiful friggin place
oh bill shut up with your stupid travel
tips yeah you know go [ __ ] yourself what
do you want from me
i went i went to three places where you
go either skiing or antiquing all right
there was no snow so what else was i
supposed to do i went up there with
version i brought some cubans out that
way i gotta lay off this habit
i really gotta i'm i'm done with the
i'm not done with it who's kidding who
but i gotta i gotta knock it down
all right
i smoked enough cigars this month to uh
i don't know what
kill a [ __ ] grizzly bear
i like them but i i'm i'm finishing
the cubans i got left and then i'm gonna
be done for a while
at least that's what i'm telling myself
ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right let's talk nhl playoffs people
i apologize to if if the energy isn't
what you're used to on this podcast uh
like i said i'm in this hotel room and
remember what happened to me in jersey
when i was screaming [ __ ] at the top of
my lungs i'm trying to avoid that
trying to avoid that
uh hey you know something i was giving
myself [ __ ]
about all my stanley cup picks and all
of a sudden every all the series is
other that they're turning around here
you know
chicago comes back and beats the blues
man that that was
amazing and devastating to watch
you know amazing for blackhawk fans but
that's all they've seen for the last few
years
so
uh
i feel less good for them and more bad
for st louis jesus christ how many times
they gonna break your heart that team is
aptly named
the blues
jesus christ
why don't you what are you gonna do you
gotta come up with a new name for that
[ __ ] team
they just keep doing that to their fans
how many times and then they keep coming
back great fans
why
do they keep blowing stairs
um
minnesota actually tied up the series
with uh the avalanche before they went
back up three to two and i felt really
good about it until matt cook blew out
somebody else's knee
once again or as he calls it finishing
his check
i saw his apartment not his apology just
talking about he has he has cleaned up
his game he actually won an award for
being the most
improved player but i just don't get
sticking your [ __ ]
i don't get
it i don't get how that's finishing your
[ __ ] check i don't why that the the
reason that you would do that
i mean he still could have brought his
stick up maybe and hit the guy in his
shoulder or something like that you
don't [ __ ] do that
but nothing i don't understand is why
the guy who decides to do a knee-to-knee
check how come both their knees don't
blow out or how come sometimes the other
guy who's doing the dirty move like his
knee doesn't blow up
i got to tell you i think stefan can
tell i think he's going uh he's going
really lenient
he only gave him a seven game suspension
and he only gave lucich
a five thousand dollar fine for stabbing
somebody
right between the balls
i don't know
this guy's like a player's coach who the
[ __ ] knows anyways the ducks
all right so
minnesota could still win that series
but that would make me happy because
what the [ __ ] they did or matt cook did
but i called the chicago series
the ducks are probably on right now
they're up three to two i picked the
ducks in that one i did pick the kings
over the shacks
that one's three to two who the [ __ ]
knows they are the sharks
sort of the west coast st louis blues
where they just put they just torture
their fans they get them all excited hey
we might do something go [ __ ] yourself
go watch a baseball game sorry about
that come back in october
you know there's certain fans they just
like like san diego charger fans it's
just like what the [ __ ] did they do to
deserve what that team does to them
every goddamn philadelphia eagle fans
well actually you know what they did you
know what they did
you can't feel bad for the philadelphia
eagle fans you just can't not all some
of them you can't the ones who actually
go to the game and are human beings but
that that core fan base of [ __ ]
animals
i mean you're surprised you're surprised
they even know what the score is
they just hose them down every game
that's it bath
give them eight baths a year eight home
games right
now canadians they wrap theirs up four
games to none
the penguins are coming back there three
to two god help you if you don't like
hockey and i picked the flyers they
actually tied it up too too now it's
three two rangers so who knows i still
make my picks might all come in
and what would that mean bill i don't
know
i don't [ __ ] know so now the bruins
get to play the uh
the blue blanca [ __ ]
though i actually like the canadians and
i like their uniforms but i just can't
stand their fans oh jesus they're so
[ __ ]
they're such [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah just the way the way they throw up
their [ __ ] hands when they think they
got robbed on a call
they're so goddamn dramatic why don't
you just take a little [ __ ] hanky out
of your front pocket and [ __ ] wave it
at the ref with three of your fingers in
the air
you know i actually went to a game there
early this year and i found they're
either like that or they're absolute
animals
they that that's that's those are
canadian fans
they're either the stereotypical french
person
minus the bo i will give them that
or
they they look like absolute animals
they look like they came in from some
northern [ __ ] province but anyways
i'm just breaking their balls all right
i think this obviously it's a bruins
canadian series
um i know we've swept each other in the
past but i just think i don't know we're
even enough
it's just never easy it's it's gonna go
there's i i don't think that they could
beat us in under seven games and i don't
think that we could beat them
in in under six
and the sixth game would be in montreal
it's got to go seven right it's got to
go seven when we both have competitive
teams at go sevens it's gonna be a
classic and i'll tell you right now
if you're not into hockey
and you want to get into it why don't
you check out the bruins uh canadian
series
um
all right so
so there's that ah jesus christ why do i
try to do a podcast after a [ __ ] show
huh
i just want to wind down and add to my
[ __ ] pasty belly that's what i want
to do i want to go down to the hotel
kiosk
and go get some [ __ ] oreo cookies
and then some of those nuclear orange
crackers and you eat the orange crackers
first you get the salt going like yeah
yeah yeah right and then you [ __ ]
throw the sugar down your throat
then you wake up the next day and your
your teeth look like a [ __ ] fruit
punch thing
i don't know what anyways i haven't been
boozing out here and i'm out of sorts
and um
so now like
i guess i'm gonna smoke cigars like can
i just [ __ ] try and do something
healthy
i watch this whole thing online that
creeped me the [ __ ] out about the
bacteria in your gut
you know it was funny as hell i actually
clicked on this thing and they got me
and i thought it was like that one of
these conspiracy
theory uh videos but it was actually an
advertisement thing because for like the
first 10 minutes like an [ __ ] i'm
watching this and this guy's talking
about food in this country
being the united states and he's going
just like
he's going like the video they don't
want you to see
and he kept going they
they this and they that and all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he was just talking
about how in your gut
you basically you have 80
80 good bacteria and 20 bad bacteria and
if you keep it at that balance you won't
be lethargic you'll have energy and
you'll basically be a healthy person and
that you know
for the most part they think that
that's the the best balance to have to
not get cancer and that type of [ __ ] so
i'm watching this [ __ ] they're talking
about probiotics foods with uh
probiotics like yogurt
and [ __ ] uh what's that what's that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that looks like onions but
it isn't sauerkraut
all right looks like caramelized onions
and never turned brown it looks like me
as a caramelized onion right
sauerkraut right olives
pickles that type of [ __ ] has probiotics
that's the good bacteria in your gut and
the 20 [ __ ]
uh that stuff is actually believe it or
not
this is really [ __ ] up
and when you talk about your your
mortality the 20 20 percent of the
bacteria the what they call the bad
bacteria
is its job is to basically eat you when
you die
i know
i don't know that's what the video said
i'm not a doctor don't take this you do
the [ __ ] research so
basically
because the food in our country is such
[ __ ] poison i guess
what is happening
to a lot of people is that the 20
is getting too high and the 80 is
dropping the good versus the bad
and it reaches a tipping point where the
the the bad bacteria outweighs the good
bacteria
and it starts taking over and it starts
[ __ ] eating away at you
like you're dead
and it can get all the way up into your
[ __ ] brain
and you start craving the sugars and the
salts that's not why i'm talking about
this stuff now i don't know if this is
true because in the end of it they of
course had a pill that was going to
solve all of this and god knows i didn't
go to medical school
not like you needed me to tell you that
[ __ ] you could just tell that by the way
i try and read out loud
right but anyways
i think the core of what they were
saying was true
because it sounded good
i'm being totally honest i didn't look
up any of this [ __ ] so i'm like you know
what yogurt has probiotics and then i'll
start eating yogurt like a [ __ ]
twinkle toes there
so i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna start
i'm gonna
what are you gonna do bill i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna eat some yogurt right
so what i wanted but i want to get the
good yogurt
all right i don't want to get the yogurt
that just says all natural or says 100
healthy for you
um no trans fats and all that [ __ ]
because you know those those
those big time corporate [ __ ] food
makers they found a way
to get around all of that [ __ ] basically
what they did was they got their own
people in the fda whatever the [ __ ] it
is they they find loopholes where they
could you know they they draw a picture
of a farm
with the sun the sun behind it 100
natural organic and all that and it
isn't
you know they're down there beating the
chickens right
cutting their beaks off that big [ __ ]
breast and they're tipping over and [ __ ]
that's that's basically still what
you're eating and they can write 100
organic and all that crap they figured
out a way around so i'm sitting there
trying to find
like i looked up all natural yogurt i'll
do it right now
just bear with me here
all right just the amount of you can't
find it
i or at least i don't know how to find
it i don't know how to find a reputable
reputable uh website that i can trust
um
that will tell me
basically where where i where the the re
the thing that says 100 organic that
actually is
organic so i just looked up organic
yogurt
and uh
and this is this is the stonyfield.com
that's the one that comes up i don't
know what their deal is so i click on
these guys
like wallaby yogurt
straussfamilycreamery.com now that's a
great name for a corporate [ __ ] farm
as they'll call it the strauss family
creamery
all right
family was [ __ ] whacked them buried
underneath the farm
[Music]
but what killed me is like i go on these
these websites and i click on them
and then they have like big like
corporate [ __ ] advertisement in the
side so it's just like you guys you guys
are in bed with the devil here
i mean maybe these guys are real maybe i
actually finally
this [ __ ] looks real now i don't [ __ ]
know
it's like when you go to like edmonds
blue book or edmonds and you're trying
to find
the actual price of a car when you go to
buy it and then you look in the side and
like chevrolet is paying for advertising
on there and like that it's like a major
red flag
it's like if you're underlying every car
salesman
at chevrolet letting him know what a
[ __ ] illumina actually cost you if
they still make that [ __ ] thing
the lumina guy the lumina right
why would they advertise
does any of this make any sense just can
you guys tell me where do i go where is
there a website that can actually tell
me
where the good food is where the food is
that's that's says it's organic and
actually is organic
now jesus did i just open up a [ __ ]
can of worms with that one all these
[ __ ] people are just gonna the amount
of [ __ ] that's gonna be written to me
and the amount of it that's gonna have
liberal or obama
i don't know you know like what the [ __ ]
i retweeted something the other day
about how
they're trying to get rid of a lot of
the freedom of speech on the internet
you know the amount of racists on there
i don't know how bad an idea that would
be sometimes but
generally speaking they're trying to sew
it up right
so it's this really creepy article about
how they're going about doing it and
pushing it through congress and all this
[ __ ]
uh so i retweet it because it's
interesting and i figure maybe somebody
smart will look at it and maybe they can
do something about it because i'm too
[ __ ] stupid so i retweet it
and then somebody writes back
right so
you're surprised that obama lied
that's what they write and it's just i
swear to god those kinds of comments
i actually feel like
those people who write those are fake i
don't believe that they're actual
citizens i think they work for the
government and they do that just to
start that stupid
republican democrat arguing with each
other so nothing gets done
you know what i mean
it's just the assumption that like
it's like i didn't vote for the guy
the guy doesn't control the [ __ ]
internet he didn't do anything the guy
[ __ ] makes 400 grand a [ __ ] year
makes 400 grand a year
he's set up to be bribed that's why i
don't vote democrat or republican at
that level it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] over okay this is just
really interesting this is gonna happen
i'm just trying to get it out there and
you're gonna rather than having people
read this
and if it is true and they want to
change it rather than going down that
road you're going to try to knock it off
[ __ ] course with that [ __ ]
so uh i don't know i gotta pat myself on
the back because i actually didn't take
the bait
probably because i only have 18
characters to call this guy a [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] they give you on on
twitter
but um
i don't know
can you do me a favor can somebody just
for the love of god start a [ __ ]
movement where people stop doing that
stop [ __ ] well it's because the
republicans forget it it's over right
the argument's over
um anyway i don't know what i'm talking
about either guys all right i'm [ __ ]
wiped out here uh let's let's do a
little bit of advertising oh jesus look
who's back it's our old friends yes
you guessed it where the hell is it
there it is our old friends
sherry's berries
they came back our good friends at
sheri's berries are back what the hell
holiday is coming up
easter already went away
oh you're gonna get this for your mother
um order giant freshly covered
strawberries from sherry's berry
starting in 1999 and over 40 savings or
the or double the berries for just 10
dollars more click on the mic in the
upper right hand corner you just need my
code bur bur when you order
um after all she went through hours of
labor
to push you out of her gross
kept you alive and fed you for years go
to berries.com and get your mom freshly
dipped berries
this is so gross for 1999 when you enter
my code burr make your mom proud with
this sweetness
they're doing this on purpose they're
just this
enormous fresh juicy mouth-watering
berries white milk and dark chocolate
covered goodness topped with chocolate
chips decorative swizzle or nuts order
your mom some sherry's berries today go
to berries.com enter the code burr and
show your brothers and sisters why
you're a mom's favorite child
this deal expires friday at midnight
make sure you order now do you realize
the amount of [ __ ] what is that an
edible con
concept
what the [ __ ] is it what's the thing
when you want to [ __ ] your mom
that was just too creepy
um anyways pro flowers
bill here at pro flowers
we get it you have a show to do you
don't want to
think up the content for the advertisers
that's our is this not what i'm not
supposed to be reading out loud
we're on your show this week to remind
you that your fans
oh i guess this is supposed to be them
okay i'm sorry we're on your show this
week to remind you and your fans that
mother's day is next week you're
reminding me too
it's [ __ ] april
uh you got to admit the woman who
brought us into the world just please
don't bring up her veg and put up with
all of our shenanigans is one heck of a
lady and ought to get some special stuff
this mother's day we're talk we're
taking a guess that you gave your mom a
few gray hairs along the way so now's
the time mother's day is on may 11th in
case anyone needs a clue fill her
special day
with one dozen assorted colored roses
with a free glass vase from
proflowers.com just for 19.99 if mom has
a green thumb up crazy
sorry upgrade
i gotta stop doing this
all right
dude you guys really need to you really
need to proofread some of this stuff
because it can be taken so many
different ways all right
upgrade to the pink potted rose or
yellow potted rose plant for just 9.99
more
your listeners can get this special
mother's day deal using your code bur
b-u-r-r order now while supplies last
besides the longer you wait the price
will go up jesus happens every time pro
flowers are guaranteed to last a full
week or get your money back the only way
to get this amazing mother's day deal is
to go to proflowers.com click on the
blue microphone in the top right hand
corner and type in bird that's
proflowers.com click the blue microphone
and type in burr this deal expires
friday at midnight make sure you order
them today all right that's enough of
that good lord
um
maybe it wasn't that maybe it was the
copy before that that got me thinking
the way i was just thinking that was
weird all right um let's get back to the
podcast
ggs um
movie 24 [ __ ] minutes in all right
what is my talk oh i got to tell you the
story uh me and verzi um
new jersey's on paul verzi
the pride of of uh
what we say the tri pride of red bank
nah he's too dumb to be in red bank
we'll say trenton
um
we were working in uh portland oregon
and we're staying at this [ __ ] hotel
right and uh
there was some sort of uh glee club
convention of people like 50 years you
know 40 50 years old
like they called themselves harmony
incorporated
and they were having like this regional
um
they were having like this this regional
i don't know what this this sing-off
thing
between these different acapella bands
not bands they just sing acapella and
every year they have a different theme
so
that this year was superheroes so
there's all these old ladies and guys
walking around with superman capes and
they're harmonizing in the [ __ ] lobby
right so me and virgie are standing
outside
smoking
these cigars right it's [ __ ] freezing
out and [ __ ] but you can't smoke
anywhere
anymore so we're standing outside
smoking these things and all of a sudden
we see this guy come walking out he's
got like a wife beater on a beer belly
and these mutton shops his jet black
hair slicked back in a big medallion i'm
thinking he's coming he's an elvis
impersonator right and he comes walking
out turns out he's like a he's wolverine
from uh
from x-men he didn't have mutton chops
it went up and around
like he had dyed his beard i guess i
don't know what whatever and he's got
like [ __ ] he's got this gardener
glove with like three butter knives
coming out of it he's got this giant
cigar and i'm like please come out here
i got to talk to this guy so we come out
there and he tells us the whole [ __ ]
story
and in the middle of us telling the
story his wife is bringing the car
around
and i swear to god
i said something and i made him laugh
and he farted
and he didn't address it
okay he's standing there
dressed like wolverine with these butter
knives coming out
and he laughed as he was telling this
story and it wasn't just like a quick
one it went like
i swear to god i thought he [ __ ] himself
and he didn't address it and he sort of
like at one point he just sort of he
gave one swat
behind his ass like to make it go away
and i think i thought he did it with his
regular hand versi insists that he did
it with his butter knife hand either way
he he didn't address it
and and i was sitting there going like
did he just fart was that version who
farted and i [ __ ] looked at versey in
verse he's looking at me he just had
this look on his face like this dude
just farted
and i had my hoodie up because it was
cold out i buzzed down my head so my
head was [ __ ] cold so i put my hoodie
up i had my hoodie up when i was smoking
when i saw varsi's face i just turned
around
and would not i couldn't look at either
one of them and i was laughing my ass
off and fortunately his wife pulled up
and i basically i left versie by himself
versi had to look at this guy and keep
the conversation going after this he
basically
basically sharted right in front of us
and never addressed it and so first he
tried to say there's your wife
pulling up with the car but he was
laughing
it made no sense he just said oh there's
your wife but you'd never laugh at that
because he just farted
he's like oh there's your wife
so it sounded like he was laughing at
his wife
like how [ __ ] up she looked but she
didn't she was beautiful
and he's like all right guys see you
later and he waves with his
his butter knives and he just [ __ ]
got in the car and drove away
looking like wove like a fat retired
wolverine
oh my god
we [ __ ] laughed our asses off and we
just kept imitating that far they
[Music]
looks like it [ __ ] came around a
corner
um
anyways that's gross what are we doing
here on this [ __ ] podcast let's um
oh you know what i just did one of those
city tours here in albany
uh i had my good friend tom lewis come
down and he uh filmed me i did a tour of
this city and it's one of these these
cities like buffalo
like cleveland like detroit where you
see the beautiful city there's just no
money here to get it going there's like
abandoned buildings and that type of
[ __ ]
you get a couple blocks over
it looks like you're in uh baltimore
you know
another great city
it's [ __ ] unbelievable
how'd that happen so i guess out here
though they're starting to make more
money because they're working on
something called uh
i don't nano something or rather i
figure what the [ __ ] it is
it's basically [ __ ] that they're gonna
maybe start putting in food
to make it last even longer like
preservatives
don't already make it last [ __ ] long
i don't [ __ ] know
either way
it'll get pushed through people will say
it's good and then you'll try it and
then someday you'll [ __ ] i don't know
one of your feet will fall off
which is why i'm just trying to find
some [ __ ] yogurt can i just find some
yogurt that can i get some probiotics in
me
i watched the advertisement they got me
they hooked me all right
but i'm not buying their pill [ __ ] them
all right
i want to buy just some yogurt can i
just get some somebody for the love of
[ __ ] god can somebody help me find
where the [ __ ] food is
that doesn't kill you can somebody do
that as i say they're smoking cigars
what a [ __ ] hypocrite
um all right let's let's read some uh
some letters for this week
um here we go podcast podcast helps me
fall asleep
um dear bill i've been a fan of yours
for years
when you played cleveland about six
years back i met you and you were so
personable
are you sure this was me
um anyways i had sleeping issues for
years i discovered your monday morning
podcast in your old podcast uh
uninformed with joe derosa
i listen to them every night and laugh
while your boston accent and yelling
helps me fall asleep
that's hilarious and takes my mind off
my day i just wanted to say thank you
and keep it up
oh that was from a lady that might have
been like passive aggressive what she's
saying like you're so [ __ ] boring i
fall asleep well uh you know
either that or you grew up in a
household like mine where everyone was
[ __ ] screaming at each other
i don't know oh i forgot i went to the
uh i went to the red sox
take me out to the ball game i went to
that red sox game the day after the uh
the day after the pine tower incident
which was so [ __ ] stupid
i mean
you know what's funny is they all know
that they do it
and i guess it's just to get a better
grip on the baseball so i mean it's
cheating because they don't allow it but
it's not really cheating
it's actually smart i mean you're
throwing an object like close to 100
miles an hour you could kill somebody
if you're having problems gripping it
because it's so [ __ ] cold
uh i mean everybody in baseball is
saying pinetard does not it doesn't
change the action on the ball
so uh i guess that's why they have the
rosin bag which is just powder and
powder doesn't work in cold weather
so everybody puts a little glob of it
somewhere
i don't [ __ ] know
um
and i gotta be honest with you i finally
just watched the video and everybody's
like oh my god dude it was so obvious no
it wasn't it was obvious after they said
it
and then everybody's like dude we could
[ __ ] see it from right field now you
couldn't
what after it happened
um
didn't we all cheer when mark mcguire
was hitting the home runs we all thought
it was great we thought he was doing
some extra curls
then all of a sudden he gets busted or
admits to it and then everybody knew go
[ __ ] yourself i was caught up in it
i went down there with christmas in my
eyes i thought him and say i thought if
he did i thought no way sami sosa did
and then once i found what both of them
broke my heart then i thought everybody
did
um
so anyways we went to the uh
we went to the red sox game
um i went down there with my mom took my
mom to the game and had a great time we
got pounded
it was [ __ ] hilarious it was like uh
i think it was seven to nothing after
three innings we'd already committed two
or three errors committed five for the
game
by the end of the game like some utility
outfielder came in and pitched for us
and uh
yeah it was a [ __ ] show it was like a
four hour
four hour [ __ ] game
and four on five minute or something
like that and uh it was
freezing cold but um
i didn't leave you know and i learned
that from my mom and i was there with my
mom so
we stayed to the end and um
it was unreal we ended up walking out
and uh the bruins game was still going
because it was uh
it was an overtime that's right critical
game too we didn't want to let detroit
back into the series
you know and tie it up two to two this
was to go up three to one and we were
walking back to the car and we walked by
a bar
and the bruins game was on in there and
i said to my mom hey you almost want to
dip in there and watch a little bit of
the bruins
and she's like sure so we walked in
there we were literally in there for
like 90 seconds that's all i saw the
game the final 90 seconds and uh dougie
hamilton came down took the shot gilnea
tipped it in and everybody went [ __ ]
nuts and i got to tell you
i really missed living back here
just how uh sports crazy it is and it's
the teams that i love like you literally
you're at the red sox game and out there
they they you know they got the
the old-time scoreboard and they still
put the bruins up there
you know instead of first inning it's
first period second period third period
then they got to the o the overtime and
they left it there for a minute and they
like well we don't have ot and somebody
finally was like well just put the four
up there they'll get it
and um
that was a [ __ ] great time
eight like an animal back here
all the [ __ ] places i used to eat at
when i was in my late
teens early 20s where i could eat that
[ __ ] and still wake up with a flat
stomach as opposed to now
looking like a [ __ ] tub of [ __ ] you
know and uh
oh [ __ ]
i'm driving back from albany and i'm
gonna hit another spot before i go to
the airport
tomorrow i'm just loading up on it and
then i'm lying to myself that i'm gonna
eat this [ __ ] yogurt this probiotic
[ __ ] and i'm gonna beat down the the bad
guys
i'd love to know where i'm at right now
with those [ __ ] things i'll tell you
right now if booze
if booze kills
the bad bacteria in your gut
um i will never decompose
how about that huh um anyways well
listen i'm glad uh my podcast helps you
uh fall asleep i guess don't tell the
advertisers that
um
yeah me and derosa we got to get that
uninformed thing going again
he's uh
he's a big fancy guy right now he's been
writing on the wonderful pete holm show
and i think they're wrapping their
series
um
their season i should say
this week so maybe me and joe will uh
maybe we'll sit down and maybe we'll
crank an uninformed out who knows
i don't want to keep raising up your
hopes because i keep saying that you
know
like that [ __ ] team that makes the
playoffs every year and then blows it in
the first round i don't be that i kind
of have been that way though with the
uninformed [ __ ] though so i apologize
anyways
um all right here's another one bill can
i make it
you guys remember that early 80s sitcom
that didn't last for too long making it
making it tooth with
we something something
this time in life i'm taking it there's
a fail to come people no more no more
fake in it i watched every episode you
ever do that you ever watch like every
episode of a failed sitcom and when it
fails you kind of feel like you failed
like i'm the only idiot that was
watching this [ __ ]
i watched hello larry every episode of
that
and i loved it they [ __ ] took that
off i watched every episode of making it
my two dads
that's actually an interesting one jody
loves chachi i watched every episode of
that and they just [ __ ] they just
made me feel dumb
then i lost all my tv watching
self-esteem and i just waited till find
out what the hits were
then i would just bandwagon on like
cheers
moonlighting and that type of [ __ ] back
in the day
how awful was bruce willis's haircut in
[ __ ] moonlighting he was doing all he
could [ __ ] do see he was starting to
lose it he had like the fonzie ducktail
ducktail or the d.a in the back and then
on top i don't know what the [ __ ] he was
doing he was poofing it up
um
you look like a balding vampire
[Laughter]
okay anyways uh bill can i make it
it was like a [ __ ] disco ball and
[ __ ] in the beginning of it can somebody
find that i've actually tried to find it
on youtube i want to say i found it one
time but i've looked it up on imdb i
can't find it i know that the theme song
was making it
i think it was
and i want to say the star of the show
actually sang the song
so he would have got [ __ ] paid
that that's a showbiz thing you might
not know showbiz there you might not
know that if you write the song
like the theme song to the show
like you get paid every time they
[ __ ] play it how awesome is that
that's why merv griffin
you know not only did he write those
games
you know create all those game shows
like wheel of fortune in jeopardy he
actually wrote like
you know when you're thinking of [ __ ]
that song
that [ __ ] thing he wrote that
so every time they played it he got paid
again
do you think you think you have enough
musical ability to come up with
something like that
how far into it could you get are you
actually good enough to come up with
do
[Music]
that's that's what makes everybody
that's the hook
and then you go oh i remember that part
from the beginning and then you're
[ __ ] in there
it's genius what a giant head that guy
had
no one he was so smart
you know he must have a huge
[ __ ] brain i bet the bad bacteria is
still munching away on that one huh
jesus that's awful
um can i make it
hi there bill my name is ben
and i'm from israel
no you're not there's nobody named ben
from israel
bans will visit israel
i thought that was like an american name
like ben franklin
you know sometimes i notice how dumb i
am that was one of those moments sorry
ben from israel all right i'm 33 years
old a father and i've recently decided
my dream is to work in comedy i've
written a lot of funny bits but sadly
the stand-up scene isn't very developed
here i'm also not a funny guy he put in
quotes so i feel it might not be
for me to uh might not be uh i'm going
to try to correct this it's not might
not be
basically my path to perform even though
i write some funny [ __ ]
how do you recommend i approach this
practice the only open mic in israel
filled with weirdos and only once a week
uh
get a funny actor friend to do my
material
find amateur nights i don't want to
waste any more time i want to make some
sort of career from comedy
um
all right
well unfortunately sir you can't rush
these kinds of things i would do all of
that
um but you the the advantage that you
have
because i know you want to do this
quickly because you feel like you're 33
years old and you gotta you got a kid
you gotta you gotta make make something
happen here
um
you're you're actually advanced in that
you
you understand your strengths and your
weaknesses
and you're trying to see if you can work
on your weaknesses to maybe perform or
go to your strength and have somebody
else perform it for you
i would try um
look the open mic is only once a week so
what the [ __ ]
what does that take that's one night out
of the week
all right the rest of the time you can
try other stuff you can try
um
making youtube videos
you can try writing scripts you can try
all of that [ __ ] and the great thing
about show business is uh you just start
doing it and then you're in the business
and if you don't stop eventually you
will start making money if you write
something that people
that appeals to people but you're never
going to know unless you do it um
my biggest advice i would give you is
quit thinking about the fact that you're
33 years old
and focus more on the fact that it's a
dream
that you wanted that you know
that you want to achieve
and um
you got to go after that stuff in life
or else you're going to have regret
um which you don't want
you know so i would just i would focus
on that don't quit your day job as they
say
just keep doing that so everything's
good and then as you start making more
money in comedy eventually you
transition over
that's all there is to it so all i got
to really say is congratulations ben
welcome to the world comedy have a good
[ __ ] time and don't be too hard on
yourself all right stay away from the
[ __ ]
the negative people and uh you know
i don't know there's no comedy scene
over there so you can create one
how about that there you go jesus christ
there's got to be plenty of [ __ ] to talk
about there
with all that stuff going on huh
you know what you should do why don't
you start a [ __ ]
an israeli-palestinian
comedy night
you know you guys all hang out and get
along
then they can do a local piece going you
know maybe politically
these two sides don't get along but when
it comes to laughing they all speak the
same language
my name is susie sundquist here's my
cleavage and i'm standing in front of
the first comedy club in israel let's go
over and talk to ben
ben how did you come up with
doing comedy with your mortal enemy yeah
the whole [ __ ] thing's right there
it's wide open
it's wide open it's like when vegas
first starts they're waiting for you to
open the casino ben
all right
there you go all right
what do we got here
girlfriends withdrawal
she's withdrawing dear bill nye the
illiterate guy
you know what's funny that's a funny
joke and i blew it because i can't read
out loud because i'm kind of illiterate
dear bill nye the illiterate guy uh big
fan of your podcast looking forward to
others
i'll get right to it my girlfriend and i
have
a very active sex life
we've been trying to
we've been trying to stay sorry i'm
still thinking of why that green thumb
made me laugh and i'm not gonna [ __ ]
tell you why
um big fan of your specials looking
forward to others i'll get right to it
my girlfriend and i have a very active
sex life
and we've been trying to stay safe
during
and she recently suggested during what
and she recently suggested that we
withhold from sex until she obtains
birth control well jesus christ yes
my
issue is that the apartment is a month
and a half away oh jesus christ dude
[ __ ] rub one out
said my bs meter is going crazy on this
all of a sudden we can't use a condom
anymore
do you think this is cause for more
concern or am i just being paranoid
thanks in advance and go [ __ ] yourself
wait a minute wait a minute
that's interesting i didn't even look at
it that way let me re-read this uh
my girlfriend and i have a very active
sex life we've been trying to stay safe
during this time she recently suggested
that we withhold from sex until she
obtains birth control
all right and it's a month and a half
away my bs meet is going crazy all of a
sudden we can't even use a condom
anymore
no i don't think that's cause for
concern
what do you think what do you think
she's doing
that's not cause for concern that's uh
you know you were getting the cookie and
now she took the cookies away and you're
kind of upset about it
um
i don't know you're a young guy so you
want to [ __ ] every day
and i imagine a month and a half seems
like a million miles away i'm an older
guy so i'm like yeah i give a [ __ ] jerk
off like twice i can do six weeks easy
[Laughter]
um
no i wouldn't she might have maybe one
of her friends
had an issue and it scared the [ __ ] out
of her and i don't know what but um what
i would do is i would sit down
and talk to her about it without being
accusatory and i would just say listen i
just want to talk to you about uh
the whole birth control thing if we
could
and there's nothing women enjoy better
than the guy actually saying i would
like to sit down and discuss something
in a relationship
they love doing that
at least the ones that you know unless
they're wired like a guy and if they are
they're like oh my god shut up
um
and just say listen you know we've
been obviously we've had a great sex
life yeah and you know i love you
you got to do that [ __ ]
that's like the beginning of a speech
welcome everybody thank you for coming
it's an honor to be up here that's what
you're doing you know i love you you're
beautiful yeah well well and then you
get to the [ __ ] point you say listen
we had a very active sex life we've been
using a condom nothing's ever happened
and
all of a sudden i understand you want to
be on birth control which is cool
i'm just making sure if there's no other
issue
um
you know because you know i find you
really attractive and six weeks is a
long ways away
and i was just wondering why we couldn't
continue to use a condom i'm not
pressuring you i'm just asking
because i really want to [ __ ] you no
don't say that last part
that's what i would do
you scots to sit down and talk to your
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um i'm married
i'm not dead
dear bill
bill the beguiling i don't even know
what that means
you know what's funny you guys all the
time are writing and saying how good i
am at giving out advice i'm the classic
person that's good at giving out advice
in that i give out great advice and then
continue to walk around and being a
complete [ __ ] idiot
you know
i gotta ge i got like everything that i
just said to that [ __ ] guy i should
be saying to myself
why don't i do that why don't i sit down
and just say hey
you know i love you you know i think
you're gorgeous i want to thank you for
being here coming here this evening
and then just be able to calmly
i don't know i got to get rid of this
[ __ ] anger man it's
it's i gotta get rid of this [ __ ]
like you know i don't have to get rid of
it but it can't be the default [ __ ]
emotion
like when i was driving across vermont
and new hampshire down to portland maine
going across route 2 the amount of times
i had a a
mild heart attack
as i'm flipping out about the douchebag
driving in front of me only to finally
you know when it becomes two lanes go
past them and see it's a cute little old
lady
and that's why they're driving slow
you'd think i would learn the lesson
like oh you know there's some old people
out here bill why don't you relax this
is syrup country they do things a little
slower up here
you know i did i just kept making the
same mistake over and [ __ ] over again
driving like a maniac you know
i made the decision to get off the
[ __ ] highway you know what happens
you know you're going to end up behind
some pickup truck pulling a couple of
[ __ ] horses
for a good hour
and i still got my i'm an idiot i really
have to conquer that if anybody knows
how to [ __ ] i go through ebbs and
flows where i'll be
my anger issues will be way way better
then they're still completely
unacceptable as versey likes to say um
but then then they start ramping up
again and it's just
[ __ ] it's embarrassing
all right anyways i'm married i'm not
dead dear build a beguiling what the
[ __ ] does that mean
look at that like right there what the
[ __ ] does that mean why could i be like
oh i wonder what that means
oh a new world new word new world no
word this is this is just a wonderful
opportunity
to learn something here in my own
podcast and you know and i i learn a lot
i learn just as much from my english and
you're hearing why can i do that right
beguile
charm
or enhance
parentheses someone
sometime in a deceptive way
okay so this is sort of a compliment but
not really
okay here we go now recently i've been
talking to a friend that i haven't heard
from in a while via facebook
oh jesus
here we go uh we continued to talk and
catch up and i found out he is married
and has a two-year-old
while
that's [ __ ] hilarious that should
come out immediately
all right while away someone
he asked me to wait
while away somewhere
oh when he was on the internet he asked
me to send him some sexy pictures
see right there the fact that you had to
we went back and forth a number of times
before he said he's married and has a
two-year-old that's not a good that
should be immediately boom
he's supposed to do that immediately i'm
married boom done
all right so this doesn't go in a weird
[ __ ] way because we used to [ __ ]
right isn't that what's supposed to
happen
um he said i said i said no and
responded aren't you married
he replied i'm married i'm not dead
oh god
he's also been flirting with me a lot
i think it's disrespectful to his wife
and to ask me for something like that
when i'm sure it would
it would help his marriage by making her
feel attractive
if he asked her
what
this was such an interesting email did i
read it wrong i think it is
disrespectful to his wife to ask me for
something like that when i'm sure it
would
i'm just say wouldn't it wouldn't help
his marriage by making her feel
attractive
i'm sure would help his oh help his
marriage if he asked her to send him
some pictures
uh okay some sexy pictures
she said i also think the flirting is
disrespectful i'm a lady by the way what
do you think
um
well yeah you're obviously right but i i
am also wondering why do you continue to
talk to this guy
you reached out to him
you didn't know he was married
okay he doesn't say he's married
so it starts to obviously it started to
go down no no no no no and then then you
found out he was married he had a
two-year-old
all right so he keeps it going
and then when he's away he asks you to
send him some sexy pictures
and you responded and said no and you
said aren't you married you knew he was
married he said he was married why did
you keep hanging around
and now he's continuing to flirt with
you why are you still talking to this
guy
what's going on with you
yeah why why are you why are you
continuing to talk to this guy this is a
no-brainer yeah he shouldn't be doing
this
this is completely uh not what you're
supposed to be doing if you are married
all right i'm not judging anybody in
this [ __ ] thing i'm just saying that
he shouldn't be doing that
and if you are offended by it you
shouldn't continue to talk to the guy
so
okay so i guess okay so wait so he
doesn't you don't send him the pictures
but you continue to talk to him then
he's been flirting with you
and you think it's disrespectful uh
yeah i mean i i don't yeah yeah it's
it's disrespectful because
he already said the sexy pictures thing
so it already brought it into a bad
[ __ ]
this guy would bang you if you'd let him
basically so he already brought it into
a bad area
um
do i think flirting is disrespectful
online absolutely if you're at work
i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean jesus christ would
work
i don't know it depends on the level of
it but you know
what are you supposed to [ __ ] do
like i'm not one of those guys if i
drive down the street
okay look i gotta tell you when i was in
i was at a stoplight by myself and this
dude
jogging by i swear to god he looked like
like marvel comics couldn't draw a more
jacked guy
like i looked at him and i went jesus
christ
his back was shredded the guy had no
fat on him whatsoever and he's jogging
down the street
no shirt on no nothing i mean this guy
must be [ __ ] everything in hollywood
even i'm sitting there going jesus
christ now if my wife was there
i i what am i gonna do
he wins
i'll tell you right now if i ran down
the street with my shirt off
that would be the end of my career
so what am i going to do i'm going to
get mad
that she's looking at this [ __ ]
statue with this goddamn greek god
running down the [ __ ] street
greek god via africa you know what i
want to get hey what the [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] i i really don't give a [ __ ]
i don't
i don't know
you don't want to talk to me when it
comes to this type of it's one of these
when i look at that stuff like
i always look at it like it shouldn't be
done it's a chris rock pick you
shouldn't do it but i understand
it's [ __ ] uh that's why the internet
it's terrible it's terrible when it
comes to that [ __ ] because
back in the day you wouldn't be able to
get in touch tom green has this [ __ ]
unbelievable bit on this
watch is special i hope he did his bid
on facebook he does this [ __ ]
unbelievable bit on it
where it's just it's just there
it's just [ __ ] there it's it's harder
than ever not the [ __ ] round i guess
i don't know but is he doing something
wrong yeah but you're i don't understand
why you
i would ask yourself why you're still uh
you're still
talking to the person i mean you reached
out that's what i'm guessing you reached
out to him because you're single right
now is what i'm guessing this was
somebody maybe you had a fling with back
in the day
or uh
you know maybe you always wanted to when
you reached out
maybe that's what you're doing and then
all of a sudden you know you find out
he's married as a kid and then all of a
sudden he shows that he would [ __ ]
around in his wife
and you're like wow this isn't the guy i
thought he was so you continue to do
more follow-up questions
just so you know your own way you can
get this guy out of your head because
you're seeing what a dirt baggie is i
got to tell you this i'm married i'm not
dead is a [ __ ] terrible line that's
the line you say to your guy friend in
the bar
you know
and she [ __ ] says blah blah blah blah
i'm like you know can't believe she said
that i mean i'm [ __ ] married i'm not
dead that's something you say to a gay
don't say that to a woman jesus christ
that's terrible
that's just blunt force trauma of truth
it's a one-two punch
he shouldn't have done that all right
whatever
i don't know what to tell you i would
just say stop talking to him
does that work
does that work for you i don't [ __ ]
know all right so somehow i've limped my
way through this podcast
oh jesus christ i have more [ __ ]
advertising to read i forgot hang on a
second hang on hang on hang on all right
here we go and then i'll tell you
another story how about that all right
hulu plus everybody
now you've probably tried hulu on your
computer hulu plus is so much more with
hulu plus you can watch current season
uh episodes of your favorite shows like
modern family the daily show and scandal
and watch every episodes of shows like
nashville lost and doctor who swap with
any red slash green color-coded shows
listed
uh you get ad-free movies and kids shows
too now more than ever there's so much
to watch take total control with hulu
plus to stream those shows and thousands
more as much as you want wherever you
want hulu plus works on your computer
your smartphone roku whatever that is
apple tv xbox playstation
pretty much any streaming device you
already own you can even watch on your
phone or ipad while on the train at work
at the dentist or in the bathroom you
can even block off a day to binge you'll
also get access to originals
um i'm sorry hulu originals that you
can't get anywhere else check out the
new show deadbeat a comedy about a pot
smoking guy who talks to ghosts
ah jesus i gotta watch that that sounds
uh binge on all 10 episodes starting
april 9th for only 7.99 a month get your
shows anytime anywhere that's like a
quarter a day everybody right now sign
up at huluplus.com bill click on the
banner on my website and get two weeks
full access completely free this is a
whole extra week more with this special
offer when you sign up at huluplus.com
bill so get with it and start streaming
tv now with hulu plus
now one of our favorites dollar shave
club everybody nothing feels better than
that first shave with a fresh blade
right it's smooth it's close and the
blade is as sharp as it's ever going to
be god damn it it feels fantastic
but thanks to the shave company
ridiculous prices you can't afford to
get a fresh blade every week can you so
you drag that damn blade that dull ass
blade across your face for two weeks
three weeks 10 weeks why do you keep
doing that to yourself maybe because the
only thing more painful than shaving
with an old blade is shelling out 30
bucks for a pack of new ones well if you
want to enjoy a fresh blade every week
but you don't want to take out a second
mortgage on your house you got to join
dollarshaveclub.com
for just a couple bucks a month
dollarshave.com ships me the highest
quality blades you can get i'm a ford uh
blade guy
and with dollar shave club it's only
six bucks for a four pack i actually
like two blades but they don't make
those anymore
at least i don't have the razor so i use
three seriously only six bucks for the
best quality blades you can get so every
week i can pop in a fresh blade and
treat myself to an amazing shave it's
incredible
um
dollarshaveclub.com gets amazing quality
blades in the mail for a couple bucks
and treat yourself to a brand new blade
every single week why wouldn't you do
that your face is going to love you
hundreds of thousands of guys have
upgraded to shaving with dollar shaved
up
dollar shape club i am one of them and
i'm loving it now it's your turn shave
time shave money dollarshaveclub.com
that's dollarshaveclub.com
jesus christ these [ __ ] things get
longer every week
legalzoom everybody modern technology is
great smartphones ipads and other
gadgets make it easy to do so many
things but why is it that our lives seem
to get busier at the same time well
because you have to charge all of them
right
no well when it comes to getting the
legal help you need legalzoom provides a
great solution that works with your busy
schedule let's face it the legal system
is complicated there are better things
you can do with your time thankfully
legalzoom is there for you so if you're
thinking about starting a business
forming an llc or getting a trademark
will or living trust legal zoom gets the
job done right you'll get the personal
attention you need and they'll help you
take care of all the details legalzoom
has been helping families and small
business owners for 14 years and they
received an a-plus from the better
business bureau call or visit legalzoom
today for an extra discount enter bur
b-u-r-r in the referral box at checkout
that's legalzoom.com discount discount
code burr
provides legal help through independent
attorneys and self-help services but
they are not a law firm go to
legalzoom.com enter the discount code
burr
all right
there we go all right that was it that
was the part okay we're good um okay i
got a youtube video of the week remember
i used to do that [ __ ]
the youtube videos of the week um
this is the one i got you guys got to
look at this one six-year-old boxer
this kid is [ __ ] incredible his dad
is an amazing trainer and he has this
kid the guy's hilarious he's like he's
basically teaching everybody else in the
neighborhood how to box
and he's like well great so now what
they're all going to beat the [ __ ] out
of my kid i don't think so so he's been
training this kid how to box and i'm
telling you this kid is throwing man
punches
at six years of age he's popping the you
know those you know the pads that these
guys put on
god help
a six-year-old that [ __ ] with this kid
they are gonna be in trouble he's
slipping punches he's throwing
combination and then jumping back
all that [ __ ] that i still suck at i
swear to god if this kid just wound up
and punched me in the face
i would be in
trouble if he caught me in the perfect
spot he probably knocked me up i got it
you got to see this this kid is
absolutely adorable
it's funny because like he's into like
six-year-old stuff
like he likes mike tyson mike tyson's
his favorite and he basically likes him
because mike had a tiger and he wants to
get a tiger like how adorable is that
like oh my god this kid's [ __ ]
adorable he's missing one front tooth
cute little kid and then he puts on the
boxing gloves you're like god damn
jesus christ
this kid would [ __ ] me up so you
definitely gotta check that out
and um
i think that's it that's gonna be the
podcast for this week hey if you guys
seriously i know i was [ __ ] around
but if you guys know any way that i can
figure out what is really organic [ __ ]
and what isn't because i even know at
those farmers markets
that a lot of that stuff is from
corporate farms and they just write a
bunch of horse [ __ ] on it so
you know you might as well just go to
the grocery store
i don't understand why i'm against money
why they're so hell-bent on [ __ ]
doing that to the food but whatever you
know the older i get the harder it is
for me to stay in shape so i i got to
try to make sure plus with all the cigar
smoking and that i got to try to do
something all right so if you can help
me out i would appreciate it um anyways
i'm going to keep watching the um
the nhl playoffs i know it's hard in the
nba version told me i was full of [ __ ]
he said the memphis grizzlies and uh
i almost said oklahoma sooners that's
how little i watch basketball the uh
oklahoma uh thunder
right
oklahoma city thunder
the tulsa turbulence whatever i heard
that that series is [ __ ] amazing i
actually really like oklahoma uh i like
kevin durant he's my favorite player in
the nba when i actually watch
all right
there
maybe i'll put on some nba now maybe
i'll watch the late game who the [ __ ]
knows that's it that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves i apologize
that it took me so long to upload this
thing hopefully
tomorrow i can find a goddamn radio
shack or some [ __ ]
and i can find the connecting wire here
that i need to upload this [ __ ] thing
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
we'll talk to you next week